it's a historic gathering for these
Sikhs in one of their holiest sites in
Pakistan they've gathered from all walks
of life from all over the world to
celebrate the five hundred and fiftieth
birthday of the founder of Sikhism Guru
Nanak it's also a special occasion
because it's the first time in 72 years
that Sikh pilgrims are able to cross the
Indian border into Pakistan a special
temple or Gurdwara has been built in the
Qatar poor area where the Guru spent the
last years of his life the little
passage they have opened should be
broadened to the extent that our broken
hearts join and love between the
countries increases so that they do not
waste time in wars anymore Sikhs are a
small minority now but Pakistan's second
city Lahore was the capital for the 18th
and 19th century Sikh Empire and many of
citizens holy places are in Pakistan for
Sikh pilgrims from all over the world
this handprints represent that of their
revered leader Guru Nanak people from
India have welcomed the opening of the
corridor but they want access to be
expanded to sites like these as well
previously Sikhs needed a visa and would
either fly to Lahore or cross via a
checkpoint in raga the corridor in Qatar
for is visa-free but that doesn't grant
the pilgrims access to other sites and
as with most things between these
nuclear neighbors the pilgrimage to was
used to send a political message if
Prime Minister Modi is listening to this
I want to tell him injustice breeds
chaos give justice to the people of
Kashmir so this whole region can be
freed as he's gathered from many parts
of the world it's also a networking
opportunity for their political
ambitions such as the Holliston movement
seeks living abroad are planning a
referendum in 2020 on the question of a
separate Sikh state in Northwest India
the Indian government calls the movement
a concoction put together by Pakistan's
intelligence agencies which Pakistan
denies but many Sikhs openly support the
idea pilgrims from India or those
planning to travel to India did not want
to appear on camera we never find that
respect anywhere in the world the
respect we get in Park
Stan being a turban sudah six according
to the UN Charter
everybody has to lie to follow their
religion and even Indian Supreme Court
has given that peacefully we can ask for
Khalistan now there is a movement going
on just referendum 2020 thing so that a
peaceful we are asking for votes we know
picking guns or anything reality is
nobody supports us we on our own money
and we spend on the discourse we are
committed to calais on even if we won't
get in our life our kids will fight for
it every people-to-people contact
between India and Pakistan is seen as a
milestone towards building bridges but
with major unresolved issues such as
Kashmir and deep mistrust from both
sides a lot more work is needed than
just opening temporary corridors Osama
bin Java down to Zahra
Hassan Abdal Pakistan